-Welcome back to "Late Night"!
We're here with Sutton Foster
and Hugh Jackman.
And it is so lovely
to have you guys.
And, Hugh,
I want to ask about this.
You were talking about,
you know,
early days of being an actor.
You gave a speech
that sort of went viral
after one of your shows,
talking about understudies
and how, I think, none of us
quite appreciate the pressure
they're under
when they have to go out,
especially for a show
of this magnitude,
and do a part.
-Yeah, I found it really moving.
I think a lot of people
understand understudy
that's been
in a bunch of movies.
But there's a thing
called a swing,
which I don't think
anyone understood.
So, Kathy Voytko,
who was the understudy
and a swing for Sutton,
who got COVID --
Am I allowed to say that?
-Yeah.
-Yeah, she got COVID.
[ Laughter ]
We all got COVID.
-No, she said that she was --
That's what
she wants you to say.
-"COVID."
[ Laughter ]
But it was like,
our fifth or sixth preview,
so no one had any rehearsal.
It was a crazy time.
Like, no one -- there's
no understudy rehearsals.
But a swing covers
eight or nine parts,
so a swing is not on stage
every night.
They're just, like,
ready to take over.
-Yeah.
-And so she arrived --
Kathy arrived at 12:00.
And we said, "Oh, by the way,
you're on tonight."
She goes,
"Oh, okay, which track?"
And I said, "Uh, Marian Paroo."
She went, "The lead.
Right, okay."
And they handed her
an abbreviated version
of the script.
Like, a little file with
all her scenes highlighted.
And said, "Don't worry, we have
like six or seven hours
before the show, so we're gonna
go through everything."
And I just saw her face
just go completely white.
And I was just blown away.
I mean, Sutton, quite famously,
became a star
being an understudy.
And I'd never done it,
so, for me,
it is so brave
and incredible and Herculean.
And Kathy went on with,
basically, running through
every scene and every song once,
and then went on
in front of 1,500 people.
And I just wanted the audience
to kind of understand that.
-It's a really lovely gift you
gave the audience, as well.
I mean, not just a gift for her,
but I think sometimes
an audience member might have
a moment of like,
"Oh, there's
an understudy tonight."
When you see that,
you should realize you're about
to see somebody do something
that requires so much skill.
-Yeah.
-And that's a really exciting
thing to be for
on any given night.
-And audiences are
actually really --
Sorry, I'm talking too much.
But audiences are really
generous with that.
Although this was the fifth in a
preview for a show like this.
The people who are going
had bought their tickets
a long way before, and Sutton is
literally the best in the world.
And I would say this
if you weren't here
or if I wasn't
on national television.
But you are, I think, the best
in the world at what she does.
She's incredible.
So people are going to see her.
So I can only imagine they're
like, "Aww!" when she wasn't on.
But they sort of rally.
-Yeah.
-And they understand the story
of it, which is amazing.
-And anything that's unique
to the night, as you said,
like that's one of
the cool things
about going to see
a Broadway show.
Like, it was different.
It wasn't the same.
And probably
wasn't they were expecting.
-It was spontaneous and alive,
yeah.
-Talk about your experience
as an understudy.
What happened on the nights
you were told to go out there?
-Oh, gosh.
Well, yes, that was --
I mean, my early days,
I was in the ensemble
and was an understudy.
And it was always a thrill.
But you had to be prepared and
ready for that phone call.
But it was always scary,
and you just try to keep
the show up and try not
to throw anybody too much.
But our company -- ooh, sorry.
Our company is --
[ Laughter ]
Our company is extraordinary,
and what everyone did,
especially when we were
first opening
and how everyone
rose to the occasion,
it was like an unbelievable,
unbelievable talent
collaboration.
Everybody just kind of came
together to keep the show going.
At one point, there were 12
people out of our --
-14.
-14 people out of our show.
And swings, Ryan Worsing
was doing seven tracks.
-Yeah.
-And they were just trying
to keep the show up.
-Does anyone know the script?
Because just come on down.
[ Laughter ]
-Dance Captain Ryan,
who's incredible,
has done 15
different tracks already.
-Yeah.
-So he's played
15 different parts.
-And he's just awesome.
And he's amazing,
and everybody just --
everyone rallies
around each other,
and they support one another.
It's the most incredible company
I've ever been a part of.
And it's really extraordinary.
-It's mindblowing when I --
Any time I see a,
be it a musical or a play
on Broadway, I can't believe
someone's learned one part.
-Right. Let alone 15.
-And the fact you have to learn
all the parts is just amazing.
-Yeah, and be confident
and, like, ready to go
and ready to sing
whatever you're supposed
to sing, and, yeah.
It's amazing.
-Well, it shows.
What you're saying about
the company shows on stage.
Congratulations, guys.
It's such a wonderful show.
I hope everybody
has a chance to see it.
And thanks so much
for being here.
-It's always a pleasure.
-Sutton Foster, Hugh Jackman.
"The Music Man," playing at
the Winter Garden Theatre
on Broadway.
We'll be right back
with Ali Wentworth.